how do i how do i like eat how do i ease
into this i don't know if you ease in
it doesn't have to be as dramatic as i'm
building enough to be i'm just
overworked i'm overworked i've been
cranking so hard i've been cranking
non-stop since i left corridor
making videos posting every single week
trying to stay consistent trying to keep
up with that algorithm man it's a grind
it is a grind especially doing
everything by myself being my own
manager my own producer i shoot
everything myself light everything do
all the v effects freaking write
everything edit everything color
correction sound design
oh it's a lot it's a lot to do by myself
and doing it every single week is proven
to be
pretty impossible impossible
if i'm trying to make great
content
i just crunch myself so hard
it's like i'm stuck in stop and go
traffic where a project comes along
and i've been chilling for a little too
hard because the last project was just
intense
and i'm like oh snap the car in front of
me is 10 cars ahead i got a full speed
ahead
so i just crank it you know i'm just
burning gas staying up really late
waking up really early to get the
project done
do this for about two weeks
friends are calling hey you want to hang
out can't hang out gotta work
dang maybe next week
and it just gets to this cycle where
like
finally i'll be able to slam on my
brakes oh eight in the morning i pulled
in all nighter i get to go to bed but
i'm sleeping through the upload and now
i can't
i can't post to twitter and instagram on
time because
i burnt myself out and i'm not
working
smart i'm not working smart i gotta work
smart i need to pace myself that's what
i'm learning it's finally time
it is finally time to pace myself
[Music]
so instead of
trying to stay consistent and post every
single week i'm going to focus a bit
more on
[Music]
putting my heart and soul
into the things
that make me happy
so what i'm gonna try out is
make a video that i'm passionate about
like this photo scanning video i'm gonna
do
uh how to build a computer for cg
artists who are just starting out
this unreal engine breakdown coming out
next week
focus on the videos that i'm actually
excited about really passionate about
and try and do one a month
and
maybe work in some guest live streams
in between that
so that's
that's my first step to pacing myself on
this channel
um
to put out better content that's what
we're trying to do trying to get a
work-life balance make better videos
and hopefully we'll all
all be happy together
i need to focus on the stuff i'm amped
about
and not the filler content not the
snacks
no snacks no more snacks maybe some
snacks
a little bit of snacks are good but
having a diet on just snacks
who can who can live off of just snacks
you're going to be frail
but have a big old gut it's going to be
weird like you're going to look
unhealthy
i need that meal
you know i need that big old meal the
meal has been prepped for a week
that's the kind of stuff i want to do
you know
so cheers to y'all
thank you for hearing me out
to my patrons thank you so much my
goodness thank you so much for helping
me out
that takes some stress off of me
to being passionate about what we do
cheers
peace out y'all see you soon
[Music]
you